and uh then I had
seven lessons that I wanted to to give
you myself so the first lesson is no
matter
whether you end up uh you know starting
a company or whether you end up working
in a company uh whether you end up in a
research lab frankly
at the end of the day you or someone
else in that company must sell meaning
sell a product sell an idea sell a thing
they must sell
and selling I think or sales is often
thought of at least because I had an
entirely technical background as well
it's you know let's go out uh drink
Scotch smoke cigars and place play golf
right that's sales
which is all good but that's not really
sales this is actually a piece of work
if you're at all interested in this area
that was done oh probably seven eight
years ago called The Challenger sale
these guys actually went and surveyed 6
000 Enterprise sales people to try to
figure out what made some much more
productive and much better than others
I'm not going to go into the whole nine
yards of this but the example of
relationship Builder is a category they
categorize sales people into five
different categories the relationship
Builder is the example I gave you of you
know oh let's go out and you know have a
scotch or go drink beer or whatever
and obviously only four percent of them
were successful the big preponderance of
success was salespeople who were
Challengers
okay
so just to tell you a little story about
relationship building as being not the
way to do this
I happened to know the CEO the CIO at
Qualcomm several years ago and we were
talking about
sales people because I hate sales people
I go okay like why Norm he goes I says I
got to tell you a story you know uh I
don't know three weeks ago the district
manager for and it was one of the large
companies I don't know oracle Microsoft
IBM or something said I have a new sales
rep I want you to meet and he said okay
I reluctantly said okay I'll take the
meeting
so the meeting began she came in and he
said he says to me he goes do you know
what she did for the next 35 45 minutes
I go and I have no idea he goes all she
talked about is the fact that you know
our kids were about the same age and you
know we should go out on picnics
together
I said you got to be kidding me and he
goes no he says exactly what happened I
called up the district manager and I
said never send a salesperson here again
so it's I I tell you that story because
this is not like an old thing that
happened 100 years ago it still happens
right so don't be a relationship Builder
be a challenger so what the hell is a
challenger the fundamental idea of a
Challenger is a challenger teaches
and the question you should then ask is
teach what
um
and the answer is teach insight
so this is a to me a very important
thing for you to think a lot about
because you will see this a hundred
times
so what is Insight Insight is the gap
between where you are today and where
you could be
okay it turns out that if you go diagram
a Steve Job speech or a Martin Luther
King speech they will diagram
identically meaning they will oscillate
between where you are today and where
you could be where you are today and
where you could be so the example I like
to use because everybody's familiar with
the I Have a Dream speech is Martin
Luther King gets up there and says I
have a dream that one day you will not
judge my children by the color of their
skin but by the content of their heart
right okay
take that sentence get rid of not judge
the kids by the color of your skin I
have a dream that one day you're going
to judge my kids by the content of their
heart
everybody goes yeah Martin we agree
absolutely
well why why were why are we out there
on the mall
and I tell people anybody who's been in
sales has seen this a hundred times
which is they walk into a meeting they
deliver what I call them my baby is
beautiful speech right here's why my
product is cheaper better faster than
anything on the planet
you know everybody goes you know you're
right you come out of the meeting you're
with your CEO you do the fist bump you
go we got this
and then I asked people what do you
think happens next
nothing
crickets anybody who's done this knows
this it happens a hundred times you walk
out of the meeting you go why didn't
they why aren't they calling me up I
thought they loved this no they didn't
love it they just agreed that what you
think that your baby is beautiful and
they agreed that you think your baby is
beautiful that's what they agreed with
what you did not do is you that you did
not teach them Insight you did not teach
them to not Martin Luther King's job was
not to get you to believe that you
should judge as kids by the content of
their heart his job was for you to not
judge them by the color of their skin
teaching you the knot was what he had to
do now let's bring it out of Martin
Luther King into the world of tech
many of you may not know this so I'll
just ask does does any of you know what
the first logo was for Salesforce
okay
I thought you would know okay what it
was was and you could go look it up was
a big knot sign
and it had software in the middle
and basically the whole thing was no
software the whole theme was no software
right and you're sitting there going
well wait a minute Mark I mean you're
you're selling a CRM software
now but what Mark went in there and did
is he said look the way you buy software
the way you install software the way you
manage software is dumb
because it was the old on-premises world
right go buy computers go hire people to
go manage it Etc that is completely dumb
he had to first convince you that that
was completely dumb and then you could
get to the questioner well I agree with
you it's completely dumb what do you
think I should do
and if any of you know the history of
the time he was competing with this big
company called siebel that had tons and
tons of features way more than
Salesforce ever had
so going after him and saying I got more
features and they're never going to win
that battle the battle he had to win was
the Battle of the way you're doing
things today is not going to work in the
future and obviously you've seen the
success it's clearly one that he won
right let me just give you one more
example have any of you heard of a
company called SanDisk
okay some of you have so sandesk builds
uh what
non-volatile memories right memory and
okay so they build non-volatile memory
let's think about their name
not disk
sand this not disk I've never been in an
early presentation of theirs but I've
got to believe they walked in there the
very first part of the meeting and said
look this sucks let me explain why disk
is not the future
and when they convince people of why
disc was not going to work
and obviously you can't just I mean you
can say it you've got to say it and then
justify why it is that you don't think
that this current approach is going to
work then you're open now to listen
so I give you this advice because no
matter what startup or whatever company
whatever new product right at the end of
the day the great temptation is to go
work on the elevator pitch the my baby
is beautiful pitch if any of you are at
startups I'm sure you've seen this and
that turns out yes I know you need one
of those but that's not what is going to
take this the sale is not against
another product it's against the status
quo
and the status quo is we use disks today
we have on-premise software today right
that's the way we do it today
and unless you can convince people that
what they're doing today and it will not
be everybody is not the right thing you
can't get to the next step
so teach teach Insight teach the not
teach with story
um this is the part of the talk where I
say to people
um I got three degrees
and I managed to do that and only take
one history class and one English class
every other every other class I had was
science math or engineering
which
in retrospect I kind of regret
because I think there's a lot of stuff
we can learn in the world of the liberal
arts
and in particular one area that I have
spent time in is trying to understand
story
so
the thing is about story is we're all
preconditioned every one of us to listen
to story why because we got told these
from the day we were born Little Red
Riding Hood or three blind or whatever
we all got told story story sits clearly
in our ears we know how to listen to
these so what is story
and I will tell you and tonight when
you're watching Netflix you can be an
observer of this there are only three
kinds of stories in the world
Man versus man man versus nature Man
versus himself
Man versus man man versus nature Man
versus himself now notice something what
I just told you these are all stories of
conflict
these are all stories of conflict if any
of you have ever read these um
reference you know oh I'm going to be a
reference for this piece of software uh
the the the article that's written
always looks like this
um you know I had this problem uh I was
walking down the street and this
wonderful piece of software arrived
solved all my problems and life is
beautiful
go read a bunch of these success stories
they all read identically right
there's no conflict in them whatsoever
they are not memorable at all
there's nothing about it that sits in
your ear
right
so I I will use my own example of this
when I and you may remember this when I
talked about the work we're doing in the
moonshot mission I started out with you
know I met Dr Chang and remember Dr
Chang was trying to help a little girl
in Myanmar and the little girl in
Myanmar he was providing Consulting for
they were trying to get an ultrasound to
him
they couldn't do it she died on the
operating room table
later on he got to see it he could have
told him what to do
now that that's a story that I know sits
in people's heads why it has conflict
it's man versus nature the little girl
died you know man versus nature it has
person place and time there's a little
girl it's in Myanmar right
become a master my counsel to you is
become a student of Storytelling
I just gave you a very brief there's
actually a project at Stanford called
this story telling project become a
student of story learn how to tell story
observe people telling story because
story is something so critical to
letting people when you try to
communicate with them to get it in their
head
story is how it gets there
and that's why I said go watch Netflix
or Hulu or whatever tonight you will see
the three one of the three examples in
everything you watch
and it is always conflict just to be
clear it is always conflict when people
do reference calls which Once Upon a
Time people did a lot of the question is
never oh you know why did you buy this
or are you happy that's all kind of like
obviously the reference is not going to
be a reference I said the question they
will always ask is what stood in your
way how did you convince your boss to do
this what was the conflict you had to
resolve the conflict is what is in our
heads what buries in our heads and I
will tell you get good at this learn
about storytelling because it's a
powerful way of communication
which leads me to
the power of language
so I used to do the first uh first line
manager education at Oracle I used to do
the one of the lectures talk about uh
management and I said to these young
managers I said well you know most of
you are thinking that as a manager what
you want is to have more people working
for you right that's kind of the goal
I'm going to have more and more and more
people
and I said yeah that's fine there
certainly are challenges in having more
and more people
but at the end of the day the big
challenge is not about owning more
people it's about owning more Minds
when you own the mind you own the people
and this is really really true when you
become more and more senior in
management is you're not sitting there
you know trying to dictate what one
person does for from eight to five or
whatever what you're trying to do is get
your team get your group get these
people to head in a particular direction
right now how do you own mind
the only way to own mind is to own
language language is how we think how we
communicate
and so I always say to people well you
know if you want to go be a successful
startup in France you better go learn
French right
I mean it the language is is
horrendously important and people I
think oftentimes are very lacks about
how they use language Let me give you an
example
um
I told you at the very beginning I
started up the cloud computing business
at Oracle one of the things that we
faced in the applications was because
these applications were never engineered
to be delivered in a consistent way
there was often times people would say
well
we we can't use it out of the box we
have to customize it
and over time Larry who's still the CEO
at Oracle would say Donna please don't
change our software don't customize it
so then the field the field sales guys
the field Engineers would go oh well
we're not really customizing we're
configuring right uh you know because
customization's bad so we're configuring
uh no we're not really configuring we're
extending it right
and after a while I kept hearing all
this coming out of the fields going what
the hell are you guys talking about what
what does this mean
and so I got one of the engineering vice
presidents I said okay I want you to
list me all the different reasons why
someone might have to change the
software that was shipped
whether as simple as adding a report
or as complex as adding a trigger
he came up with 26 different classes
uh I took all the words I usually hate
acronyms but I took all the words I had
heard customization extension
modification
localizations Integrations and I put
them all together in one word in fact
for a little while it was on Wikipedia
it was
c-e-m-l-i was the acronym
and we actually taught people how to
pronounce this word right it was
pronounced chemli
and and so we kept using the word
explaining to people what the word was
what was fascinating was within less
than a year you could figure out in the
very first conversation whether that
team was part of our tribe or not
because they either exactly knew what
the word meant or they were looking at
you going what are you talking about
and over a longer term the whole
Consulting organization actually adopted
the framework and adopted the word I'm
using that as a simple example of owning
language and owning a word as an example
of owning what people think about and
how they think
and so as you go and you know work in
some company or start your own
how you communicate and remember I made
the comment about Sid and you know the
written word it's another example of
this the words you choose the language
you choose
that is extremely powerful and make them
make the choice of that language don't
be sloppy about the language because if
you are then you cannot communicate with
people if one day you're saying uh you
know I'm calling it a edge server in the
next day an edge cloud and the next day
an edge computer you're you know what
did you mean so the consistency of
language your choice of that language
very powerful in making sure you're
communicating and you're I'm going to
say it owning people's minds
lesson five
manage your career
so as you know I keep like tell stories
so I'll tell you another story
this is a guy I went to graduate school
many years ago
he calls me up one day and we haven't
talked in probably 20 years
and he said you know I uh I just got
laid off
um really liked some advice so I said
cool so we go out to lunch we sit down
and I basically walked through his
career
and I will describe it
succinctly as
I did a little of this and then I did a
little of that and after that I did a
little of this and then I did a little
of that
it was the most random walk thing you
could ever imagine
and so he's sitting there
25 30 years later
without really a career he's just done
stuff
for 30 years
and I I really counsel people to you
know no one no one is going to manage
your career for you that's not going to
happen a long time ago you might have
you know gone to work for some big
company and they would have done it no
nobody does that right you're
responsible for it
and the way I try to get people to think
about it is particularly in Tech is you
cannot be static I've seen this many
times
uh where people go oh you know I'm going
to be the world's greatest expert on
this and 15 years later no one cares
about it I'll give you my own example of
this uh all my
graduate school work I did a lot of work
in computer architecture remember I
probably told you when I started out I
started teaching at Stanford I taught
computer architecture computer
architecture meaning instruction set
architecture was a very cool subject for
a long time
uh I mean every every computer company
had their own multiple architectures
within a one company it was a very cool
subject but quite rapidly uh the folks
at Motorola
and Then followed by the folks at Intel
and the folks at MEPS basically started
to standardize architecture so the job
of being an architect at this point in
time is like you know there's probably
two places in the world that you can go
to right
so I like to say to people you should
think about living in a I'll call it
10-year cycle
two to four to learn meaning okay I and
this is putting it on you to think about
where are things headed right so to
learn about where are things headed are
things headered to I don't know
generative AI are things headed to Edge
Computing or things that are de
Federated learning I happen to believe
some of this but you need to make that
on your own by talking to people
observing whatever and then
starting to learn becoming more and more
of an expert on the thing which you do
not know how to do
so that you can then head to the do part
of the cycle and end up being a
practitioner of generative AI or
whatever the subject matter is
but think about it as a cycle it's not a
one and done
I mean you know you've heard the
lifelong learning story I think many
times in fact all the folks at DCI here
are examples of thinking about the world
as you know I got to keep learning and I
really counsel you to think that way
think that way because it's the way you
want to manage your career you want to
be thinking about where the future is
you want to be learning you're all great
students about the thing that is going
to be in front of you so that you're
never going to be Obsolete and you will
be managing this you're the making the
choice of doing that
and I I really counsel you to spend the
time lots of people spend lots of time
on a lot of other things and they don't
spend time on their career and if you
think about it it's like one of the
biggest assets you have so manage it
uh lesson six
you have the best email address the just
how how long I've been teaching this
class uh this slide used to say you have
the best business card you're ever going
to have and I just changed it because I
go who the hell has a business card
anymore but uh you have the best email
address you're ever going to have
all right
um
I will tell you pretty much anybody will
answer your email because it says
stanford.edu
uh and your student
and you know you want to know about
something you want to meet somebody you
want to learn something
they're all going hey she's a student
right
as soon as you take a job with pick your
poison you know Google Facebook Twitter
whatever it won't be that way anymore
because people will go oh well why do
you want to know that right
so you have this unique opportunity
don't squander it for this period of
time while you're here to use that email
address to reach out to meet people to
learn things
Etc uh you're never going to have a
better one some people have asked me uh
well how Tim how do you get all these
speakers to come here
that's part of the answer to the
question
I mean I'm not sending them and when my
first email to Alex was not from my
Gmail account
right
uh so take advantage of that by the way
take advantage of this campus to all
this I mean you're sitting in the middle
of you know more intellectual horsepower
than most places on the planet and a lot
of students come to class they sit here
they do their homework they go home four
years later they missed on a great
opportunity
um you know to learn about things that
may not be your major but you may be
curious about in any number of different
areas use that opportunity use this
email address uh it ain't going to get
better than this okay
um
I was struck by uh
a comment Jamie McKeon made in our last
lecture about work-life balance
I first ran across this we had Patty
Pope I I made the comment when I
introduced Jamie that I I really make an
effort to try to get women CEOs of
public companies which they're not a
whole lot of them we got Patty to come
it was probably four years ago Patty was
CEO of CMS energy so CMS energy is
Michigan's Energy company publicly
traded company
um so she she got up here and she
started she goes
um
lots of people asked me about work-life
balance
she says I think it's the wrong question
I think it's because I'm a woman that
they asked me this which is why I was
struck when Jamie made the same comment
she says I don't think you ought to
think about life that way
and she proceeded to do a 10-minute
lecture on this idea which some of you
may have run across called ikigai it's a
Japanese philosophy and in essence what
it says is that your task in the world
is to find that place which is the
intersection of things that you do that
you love things that you're you're
passionate about
things that you're good at
things you can make money at
and
things that the world might need
and the your effort your triangulation
or quadrilation to being able to move
through that space to find the place
which best intersects these four
objectives
she said that's how she thinks about
living her life is this way
uh she did a fantastic lecture uh you
know talked about how as an example
she's already done the math that in
Michigan they'd never need to build a
new power plant of any form for the next
50 years if they could just be able to
manage out to the end points which was
very interesting for her to say that
so at the end of the lecture I'm walking
around I said to her I go you know uh
yeah I wish you'd come here and run PG e
so some of you who watch TV might know
that about nine months ago Patty became
the CEO of Pacific Gas and Electric our
local gas company so actually this time
I sent our note saying would you come
back she said I'm really busy so I said
okay fine but anyway so I think it's a
piece of wisdom that she had that I
thought was very useful to think about
and to use to guide you know what is a
complex activity